hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the oneplus one it's a new phone from
a new manufacturer and it's gotten a lot
of attention it's actually one of the
most polarizing phones i have ever seen
so over in the tech community this phone
is almost impossible to get people are
swarming over this phone there's way
more demand than supply there's an
invite system
it's just really really hard to get your
hands on but then i go over to class and
someone says hey what phone is that and
i say it's the oneplus one and they go
the what i don't i don't really know
what that is so clearly there's a big
divide over who cares about this phone
why
the short answer to that question is the
price this phone when it's available
will cost outright three hundred dollars
for the phone off contract for
perspective the iphone 5s will retail
seven hundred dollars off contract the
galaxy s5 700 off contract the htc one
seven hundred dollars off contract so
when you put up a phone with very
similar specs to that and it costs only
250 off contract it's turn a lot of
heads in the tech community and that's
because we care about specs so let's try
to find out if this is worth caring
about the specs for this low of a price
so just to get it out the way it is
rocking a 2.5 gigahertz quad-core
snapdragon 801 chip the adreno 330 gpu
three gigabytes of ram a 13 megapixel
camera a 3 100 milliamp hour battery all
very similar specs to something like the
samsung galaxy s5 and on top of all that
for a premium slab style phone the
oneplus one is built really well i
actually think its design is one of its
best assets so this white version here
is extremely soft to the touch and they
advertise that a lot it's super soft and
yet it's also very durable it feels
really solid in the hand thanks to all
the metal involved around the frame so
all the way around the phone no matter
how you hold it you're touching metal
somewhere and it really does actually
have the perfect button placement for a
big phone yes it's big it's that 5.5
inch 1080p display but the power button
is low enough on that right hand side
and the volume buttons are low enough
that it shows that they actually took
some notes they actually thought about
where to put these buttons and it keeps
the phone pretty usable to even someone
with smaller hands uh more comparable to
the smaller five inch or 5.1 inch
display flagships it's also pretty thin
so really the design is one of the best
points about the oneplus one so with the
beastly specs and pretty top-notch build
quality it seems like you're getting a
lot for your money for this phone and it
certainly feels like it when you're
holding it again it feels like a beast
of a phone uh you also have lte 802.11
ac wi-fi a big battery too like i said 3
100 milliamp hours but it's not
removable although you can take off the
back and soon you'll be able to replace
the back with other covers of different
materials and i also noticed that this
phone has three microphones one on top
one on the back and one on the bottom
leading me to believe the audio quality
would be great and it was and calls but
for some reason the call volume of the
person i was talking to was super low
like i cranked the volume and i could
barely hear who i was talking to which
was weird but i guess that can be fixed
with a software update but for other
apps the speaker sounded just fine maybe
even a bit above average since it's real
stereo instead of fake stereo like the
iphone or the nexus 5. so if you've been
looking really hard for a flaw that
makes this phone's hardware worth really
less than the other 700 flagships it's
trying to kill you probably haven't
found it yet and neither have i i mean
i've been using the phone for weeks as
far as i can tell this phone is pretty
much flawless a miracle piece of
hardware for the price and i've been
damn impressed with using it but really
guys this phone is super similar on the
inside to a lot of those other 700
phones thanks to the specs inside so
what really differentiates it what
really makes this a different phone is
actually the software uh it's
cyanogenmod and like i said in that top
five video i did not too long ago for
all intents and purposes this is a
cyanogenmod phone this is going to
depend on the features and the awesome
stuff that comes with cyanogenmod 11s so
it's a custom built os for this phone
based on the latest version of android
4.4 kitkat and it's definitely filled
with extra features specifically for
this hardware which is nice to see i've
talked about some of their stuff before
so it lets you choose a lot of things to
really customize your vanilla android
like experience so you can really make
it your own you can make it seem very
much like a nexus almost stock like me
or you can hop in the theme manager and
really go crazy all out customizing not
just your wallpaper and your icons but
your boot animation and your lock screen
and everything all sorts of stuff
and there are custom features like being
able to choose between on-screen
software buttons or off-screen
capacitive buttons depending on what you
like you can't do that on any other
phone you can also customize what the
software buttons show up by adding or
subtracting or reordering them however
you like so there's tons of stuff here
that you'd probably be used to finding
in a custom rom because really that's
what this is it's cyanogenmod even
though this device is not rooted out the
box another cyan engine mod feature is
you can say hey
snapdragon snapdragon
hey snapdragon
hey snapdragon
and sometimes it decides to wait and
work and other times it doesn't uh when
you do it opens up google now and you
have to train your voice for a while i
haven't found this to be really all that
responsive but like you just saw it does
work sometimes they've also custom built
a lock screen so it blurs your wallpaper
or since it's android 4.4 will also blur
whatever album art of whatever music
you're listening to while it's playing
which is really cool and i'm actually a
pretty big fan of this lock screen just
because it's a big screen and not
everyone can reach the center with one
finger so just swiping down from
anywhere in the middle is pretty
convenient if you're trying to use the
device with one hand and of course you
can always swipe to get into the camera
directly from the lock screen as well
and they've custom built a few other
apps like the audio effects control
which works really well for listening to
music
the themes browser again like we
mentioned the gallery and the camera app
so this is a custom built one by
cyanogen again it's kind of a cross
between the old google camera and the
new one but i do like how easy it is to
switch between shooting modes they made
it really easy here just a vertical
swipe up or down to move between modes
so i actually found myself using this a
lot just to quickly switch to hdr real
quick i used to use it all the time just
because of how easy it was and the
camera itself on the phone was
surprisingly nice to me like i've heard
some other people didn't really like it
that much but i think it's pretty good
certainly better than the google play
edition 1m8 i'm coming from so it takes
13 megapixel photos and it's capable of
4k or slow motion video and i'm actually
a fan of how low profile the physical
camera itself is people don't really
talk about it that much but it reminds
me a lot of the oppo find 7 here which
is probably the phone that this is
physically most similar to and it sticks
out just a tiny little bit but i say
good job to them on keeping the camera
pretty small and low profile and the
actual pictures it takes look pretty
nice so there's no optical image
stabilization
but it does have dual led flash and
multiple lenses and everything else
you'd expect from a nice camera and the
photos were detailed and saturated and
well colored and sharp i actually like
the action mode because it forces a
faster shutter speed which freezes stuff
at the expense of a bit of a higher iso
but it does reduce blur really well so
it almost kind of makes up for that lack
of stabilization low light pictures
again were okay compared to other decent
phones i mean this is a solid camera
i mentioned in my find 7a review that
i'm a fan of the slightly over
aggressive hdr and we see it again here
almost the exact same way i mean this
one plus one camera is where i was
probably fully expecting to be let down
by the price tag but nope gets a thumbs
up for me here so the only real con here
in this phone is cyanogenmods bugs which
is good and bad bad because it's the
whole os and it's a custom os built for
the phone so you'd expect it to be
perfect i guess but it's also good
because even though it's not perfect it
can be fixed with software updates so
during my use of this phone i kept
coming across little force closes and
little errors that i just don't normally
see on other phones and a lot of them
were easily reproducible for example if
you open up the camera app directly from
the lock screen then hit the kind of
invisible home button your wallpaper
will glitch a bit and black out the
bottom part and will not fix itself
until you sleep the phone and then wake
it again where the bottom part of the
wallpaper reappears kind of weird but
happens every time little stuff like
that
regular performance you know zipping
around the phone and multitasking is
just fine opening and closing apps
animations frame rates are all high even
gaming is pretty great i've played a
couple of games on this phone i'm not a
big gamer on my phone but it's it seems
solid but this is where it really gets
weird really almost all of the other
animations throughout the os are fast
except for the home button now of course
i have on-screen buttons but i tried
this with the off-screen buttons too and
i got the same issue the home button
response time is super slow a lot of you
guys mentioned this in the top five
video like what is that lag coming from
uh it's not really a lag it's just a
palpable delay a delay between hitting
the home button and then actually
starting the animation to go home it's
so big of a delay that a lot of us
notice it every time and it got annoying
for me so i actually put it up next to
the google play edition 1m8 like just to
make sure i wasn't going crazy and sure
enough yeah it's got some serious delay
and i don't know why the other buttons
don't have a delay the back button is
actually faster
and the multitasking button works just
fine so i thought it was waiting for a
home double tap to see if i was sleeping
the screen but i turned that option off
so i really have no explanation for this
massive intrusive delay for the home
button and i can only hope cyanogen
already knows about this issue and is
working to fix it with a quick
over-the-air software update so that's
kind of the story of using this phone i
love the hardware and using it and
everything it just doesn't feel quite as
polished as a nexus or another high-end
flagship when i'm using it and that's
evident by the little software problems
here and there the occasional delays and
force closes when working around and
trying to use all the awesome features
of this custom operating system so at
the end of the day yeah this phone comes
down to signage and modern whether or
not cyanogen can keep improving and keep
sending updates to this phone i've
already gotten one in the time i've
spent with it and whether or not they
can live up to these specs because i
would really expect a phone with such
awesome specs like this to perform kind
of like a 700 phone i'm not expecting it
to match every part of that phone but i
expected a custom os for a brand new
company's phone to to at least perform
optimally on it so really this phone is
going to live or die on cyanogenmod and
whether or not the updates come and keep
it stable like it would on a nexus
because you can already expect that to
happen on a nexus
so yeah this is a really impressive
phone i am i am really big fan of the
hardware i like how soft the back is i
like how sturdy it's built i like the
specs i like the way it looks it is a
big phone but i have big hands i don't
mind that and i can understand why
people are clamoring over this phone
especially in the tech community i don't
think you should smash a 700 phone to
get it but hey marketing is marketing
and this is a pretty well priced phone
for what you're getting for the money so
i say if you're willing to take that
risk in cyanogen mod
and you think they're going to actually
maintain it and update it like a nexus
is pretty much guaranteed to be from
google and you want that experience for
a hundred bucks off
it might just be a damn good deal for
the risk you're taking so if you trust
them do it it's gonna be worth it i
don't have any invites i can't get you
an invite if you're trying to get this
phone i'll keep you guys updated on
twitter of course in the link right
below that like button for availability
and things like that if you're trying to
get your hands on it but uh for now
there might be a giveaway coming up
maybe soon but really the idea here is
uh if you're trusting cyanogenmod it's a
pretty good pick so there you go guys
thanks for watching this review video
hope you enjoyed it again there's a
thumbs up button below to click if you
liked it and i will talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
you